Azamat de meyer is the german
correspondent for Zaman Turkey's largest
circulation daily newspaper he made a
special trip from Berlin to Munich to
pick up his accreditation to attend the
trial of Beata chiba a key member of the
so-called National Socialist underground
and four of her alleged accomplices but
like all other foreign journalists he's
been excluded the way this happened may
be technically correct but this is an
exceptional trial we pray that something
like this never happens again Turkish
citizens were killed and in a case like
this the authorities should consider a
different approach and at least free up
a few places for Turkish journalists
here in the Munich neighborhood of Hamas
daf within a hundred metres of a police
station a fruit and vegetable seller
named Hibiki leach was killed he was
shot three times in the head he was the
fourth victim of the so-called NSU the
radical right-wing terror group that
consisted of they are Toshiba /
Bernhardt and averment Lewis the fruit
and vegetable stand is still there today
it's had several different owners in
recent years Azam addameer meets a
friend of the coolidge family their
relatives don't want to speak publicly
about the case the family still
traumatized by Kelly's death and how the
authorities handled the case they
suspected us of being involved when they
questioned us they took everyone's
fingerprints and DNA samples anytime
there was a murder they called us to the
station and asked the killer's family if
they knew so and so if there was a
connection it never stopped
ten murders eight of the victims had
Turkish origins one was German and Greek
and one was a German police woman the
NSU also set off a nail bomb in Cologne
that wounded many people back then
people called these murders the Derner
murders unfortunately people thought it
was the Turkish mafia or had to do with
prostitution or gambling a lot of rumors
started about people who were no longer
around to defend themselves despite an
increasing body of evidence police
failed to follow up on hints that the
killer's might be right-wing terrorists
Beata chip and her companions were able
to go about their lives undisturbed for
13 years political scientist - ca' has
criticized Germany's domestic
intelligence service which employed paid
informants within far-right circles
many say that that practice hindered the
investigation they have stated
definitively that they don't want to
explain themselves when it comes to
their informants they've blocked
attempts to clear it I and the failure
of investigators is a central part of
this case the two Deeks is fuzzy and as
he has been it's not just about the
murders but also why they failed to
discover a pattern earlier - a dictum
Azam addameer spent many hours with the
NSU parliamentary investigative
committee in Berlin he was amazed at the
mistakes that were made including
document shredding he couldn't believe
that no one connected the murders for 13
years there are still many unanswered
questions where informants actually
involved was one of the members of the
NSU and informant these are very
important questions and I hope they'll
be cleared up during the trial the NSU
trio of Chapin mundos and Bernhard
disappeared in 1998 after explosives
were discovered in Boone Hatt's garage
the group lived in secret surviving on
the proceeds of bank robberies committed
by the two men
in the town of speak about cheaper
disguised herself as a pleasant neighbor
in 2010 moon glows and Bernhardt were
pursued by police after a failed bank
robbery they burned down their mobile
home and killed themselves
Beata chiba set off a bomb and their
shared home it's the Kohen fled three
days later she turned herself in to the
police a parliamentary investigative
committee has tried to reconstruct what
happened if a Huggle is part of the
committee she and her fellow members
have had to recognize that authorities
massively underestimated the scope of
the extreme right-wing milieu in germany
they haven't done anything
no one has from the security services to
the police and domestic intelligence and
even the courts and politicians that's
the first thing and the second is that
there was a truly prejudiced view of the
victims who had immigrant backgrounds of
Fatima God's own center contact Azam
Adhamiya still has hopes for the muna
Court despite all the mistakes that have
been made so far he wants an explanation
of what happened and justice I believe
that Germany is a country where the rule
of law applies but I also expect the law
to be applied and these groups have to
be exposed whatever their origin or
their views they have to be arrested and
go to trial and go to prison da Mia
wants to be there to look be out at
shape and her alleged conspirators in
the eye whether he gets a seat at the
trial or not